[Musique]
djamel bouras bonsoir alors vous aurez
besoin à l'occasion dans les lumières
qui viennent d'expliquer ce qu'on veut
dire si vous êtes champion du monde de
judo olympique champion olympique de
judo
il confond avec la boxe très graves si
bien et on va voir donc l'histoire vous
nous raconter l'histoire qui nous est
arrivé
francis lalanne bonsoir
et gérard miller
[Applaudissements]
comment
d'où des fautes 1
otez moi d'un doute c'est le gérard
muller de france inter c'est le gérard
miller qui est tous les jours et coûter
par deux millions deux cent cinquante
mille personnes dans tous les sens où et
qui est en victime des médias
il est pas victime les médias mais il a
un avis sur les médias l'un a dit
surtout gérard muller non
ouais je vous écoute tous les jours mes
parents vous trouve mes chances par zep
est méchant bon d'accord
alors on va commencer avec vous francis
lalanne d'abord votre actualité
moi je ne suis pas une victime des
médias donc j'ai pas une victime les
médias vous avez quand même je suis pas
là pour ça je suis là pour parler de la
sortie de mon livre et de mon spectacle
au bataclan mais on va en parler en
masse le 12 février on va là on va
commencer dans l'embarras donc je tiens
à dire que en ce qui me concerne je n'ai
je n'ai accusé ni personne d'aucun crime
concernant wii puisque pour moi le monde
médiatique est un monde qui s'exprime et
on connaît sont engagées que partir du
moment où on connaît son langage on
accepte ou alors qu'on ne fait pas ce
métier vous voulez plutôt refusé parce
que vous avez quoi moi clairement ses 12
heures on peut dire quand même que vous
êtes quelqu'un qui a toujours eu maille
à partir avec vous et quand mme boxer
pas mal vous c'est pas le judo c'est la
boxe vous avez beaucoup c'est quand même
pas mal de photographes pas mal de
journalistes est toujours été un peu
rebelle par rapport au système
médiatique et vous l'ont fait payer
personne ne m'a rien fait payer et je
n'ai boxé personnes contrairement à ce
qu'on peut lire dans la presse mais
attend tous les articles qui sont dans
vos dossiers de presse et qui concerne
les bagarres vous avec des reporteurs
avec des gens et ça c'est faux écoutez
la façon dont l'histoire est racontée et
bien entendu fossat et je viens de
raconter la vraie alors je pense pas non
moi je pense que vous avez jeunesse il
faut parce qu'il n'a peut-être jamais
bossé flex personnel a commencé ce soir
mais ce que tu veux dire c'est que un
jour jean cocteau a dit je suis un
mensonge qui dit toujours la vérité
je crois que c'est un petit peu une
phrase qu'on pourrait appliquer au monde
médiatique le monde médiatique n'est
plus là pour informer les là pour
distraire on le sait est hélas vont va y
suit les tendances qu'ils pensent être
celle des autres c'est à dire du
spectateur et qui souvent ne le sont pas
d'ailleurs
et quand on pense que les gens ont
besoin de potins on leur sort du potin
quand on pense que les gens ont besoin
des missions culturelles on leur sert
des miss octobre en fait les gens ont
besoin de choses très saine
mais comme ils sont très fatigués quand
ils rentrent du travail bas
il regarde ce qu'on montre à la télé et
puis ils prennent ce qu'ils mangent et
lorsque je viens c'est quoi ça fait sept
ans par exemple qu'on vous a pas vu on
peut pas dire qu'on leur montre souvent
francis lalanne moi j'ai dû faire à peu
près une dizaine d'une quinzaine de
télévision à 20 ans c'est un choix
personnel
j'ai eu la chance d'arriver dans ce
métier à une époque où le monde
médiatique n'avait pas autant
d'importance et les gens sortaient de
chez eux ils allés à la rencontre des
artistes est un petit peu ce qui est en
train de se passer maintenant grâce à
l'avènement du du rap du tout les
groupes alternatifs qui se produisent
dans des lieux non non subventionnées
enfin dont vous avez décidé d'être
marginal en quelque sorte que ça se
passait mal un génial par rapport à quoi
et par rapport à qui par rapport aux
médias était alors moi on s'est
rencontré il ya 15 ans dans une émission
sur tf1 que serait le scoop à la une je
m'en souviens très bien m'avait glissé
de france génial m'a dit quand vous
étiez sur scène et que ça se passait
très très bien vous jouissiez dans votre
votre j'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit que j'ai
il m'était arrivé de ressentir un
plaisir extrême avant le regardera
d'abord tirer si vous pouviez arrêté
parce que vous êtes à côté wallon
en fait je veux dire c'est qu'on s'est
connus or 15 ans elle avait retenu que
ça de francis larger pas retenu que ça
cela dénote un certain état d'esprit
mais ça mais je suis on est là moi je
vais revenir aujourd'hui
non mais il est parvenu une fois dans
double jeu non ce que je veux dire
simplement c'est que vous avez été mis à
l'écart des par les gens des médias
atteint personnes ah bon alors parlons
de vos spectacles vous faites une
comédie musicale avec herbert pagani au
bataclan qui s'appelle megalopolis ouais
bah parlons-en c'est quoi eh bien
puisque je suis venu pour ça je vais
donc en parler
cher cher thierry il s'agit donc d'un
spectacle d'une comédie musicale dans ma
très jeune carrière puisqu'elle n'a que
20 ans je n'avais encore jamais
participé à une comédie musicale et elle
a été mise en scène est adapté de
l'oeuvre d'herbert pagani par un jeune
metteur en scène qui s'appelle bernard
habitants dont j'avais vu un spectacle
il ya quelques années qui m'avait
bouleversé qui s'appelait le sel et le
miel et donc il a adapté l'oeuvre de
pagani la trouver dans les chansons de
pagani des personnages ce qui est
extraordinaire ça raconte quoi alors
megalopolis à raconte une histoire très
contemporaine qu'est qui va vous plaire
je pense thierry vous qui êtes un
publiciste c'est-à-dire un polémiste et
non pas quelqu'un qui fait la publicité
ça raconte l'histoire d'un monde qui
consensuel qui s'enferre dans le dans
les haras dans l'est le marasme de la
pensée unique c'est à dire vous savez on
n'est plus dans un monde totalitaire
aujourd'hui où là le pouvoir s'exerce
par la violence armée
on est dans un monde subliminal où la
violence s'exerce par une dialectique
très simple qui est celle de
l'alternance de la caresse avec une
manipulation médiatique qui tend à
culpabiliser celui qui ne pense pas la
même chose que la majorité met pas
souvent à la télé mais quand vous venez
à damien après sont infinies non mais
c'est très bien le seul mot que je veux
dire si vous permettez chat me suis
empressé que l'expression de cette vie
intime c'est à dire de la relation
amoureuse qui pratiquent entre eux où la
relation d'amitié qui pâte kit pratique
entre eux et bien s'est présenté comme
étant finalement aujourd'hui la réponse
au pouvoir vertical je crois que plus
aux villes intime plus envie d'amitié
plus envie d'amour personnel et plus on
y rebelles voilà ce que racontent ces
titres est bien gérard miller ça vous
branche d'aller voir cette pièce
[Applaudissements]
non je n'ai mis si je réponds oui
non non non le dire non non je trouve
que vous l'avez bien présente et moi je
vous en remerçie vrai bien présent on a
le droit de ne pas adhérer
moi je suis tellement pour la liberté
d'expression je suis même pour le droit
à l'injure envoyée ouais je préfère
qu'un journaliste 10-15 mensonge et qui
n'arrête pas de dire une vérité je vais
pas justifier ce que je vais dire
maintenant parce que je connais bien la
lan d'abord parce que j'étais ado
j'allais voir quand il chantait sous les
chapiteaux à l'époque
et puis ils étaient très bons comédiens
aussi dans l'affrontement avec jean piat
mais bon évidemment il a des défauts on
les connaît les défauts de la lan il
s'emporte facilement est un peu parfois
je garde mon calme vous avez pu vous
connais bien vous emportez un peu
facilement est-ce que c'est pas un peu
de la provoc quand même d'appeler ça
megalopolis mais gano a les cannes à
m'écouter moi j'ai déjà écrit tous les
articles mégalo francis mais un machin
ou bon mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que c'est pas moi qui écris le titre et
megalopolis on va faire un peu
d'étymologie un peu de grecs police et
la ville mégalo vous connaissez la
grande veillée c'est un hasard bon et de
toute façon le regard des autres
n'engagent qu'eux-mêmes et le regard des
autres moi ne m'a pas vous savez que
vous allez au-devant des critiques avec
ce titre d'un il a l'habitude non mais
écoutez on quand on fait ce métier on va
au devant des critiques mais on va au
devant de joie qui sont bien plus
immense que les petits des plaisirs que
peuvent nous causer la presse
[Applaudissements]
j'ai passé souvent à côté du théâtre où
francis lalanne jouer l'affrontement
c'est quelqu'un qui va au devant et
chauffe c'est important c'est quelqu'un
qui écoute et ses galeries qui alors je
sais pas comment la pièce appelée
l'affrontement moi j'ai jamais vu
comment c'est pas le flatter parce qu'à
vous clamez berne
comment s'est passée pas un prince et
moi sujet un verbe un compliment
est-ce que les biens alors ce luxe à
fait légal ou idéal épigrammes amoureuse
et vous dites que il faut lire une page
juste avant de faire l'amour à chaque
fois oui enfin je certain nombre de pas
savoir quand même jour ses radios elles
sont bien s'il ya cent poèmes non mais
c'est un conseil moi je pense que
l'amour l'amour charnel un mouchard neil
a aussi besoin de mots et je pense que
les poètes c'est leur rôle de donner des
maux aux plaisirs dire aussi ponton
alors ça dépend avec une journée bien
sûr et puis depuis sept ans à vous étiez
où j'ai fait bien des choses là mon nom
interruption de la direccte d'activité
de deux chanteurs est dû avant tout au
fait que j'ai eu un procès avec une
maison de disques dont kim a interdit
pendant des années puisqu'il a duré sept
ans cinq ans exactement m'interdit de
d'enregistrer et donc c'est pour ça que
j'ai pas pu le faire donc j'ai développé
d'autres choses j'ai développé la
littérature j'ai publié des livres de
poèmes j'en ai j'en ai dit et d'autre
j'ai développé l'art dramatique puisque
j'ai joué pendant trois ans avec jean
piat de saison à paris une tournée en
province
et puis j'ai gagné mon procès est donc
maintenant ça nous permet de pouvoir
prétendre à enregistrer un nouvel album
ce que je suis en train de faire en
français pour moi en espagnol aussi pour
une tournée que j'avais fait en amérique
du sud et j'enregistre également l'album
du spectacle megalopolis qui sera versé
en trois albums donc j'ai un drap pour
vous que vous êtes occupé des petites
figurines aussi alors j'ai également
pendant cette période
relancer une entreprise dans le périgord
qu une région que de vous devez
connaître
je cuisine devient connais bien quitter
l'entreprise
parle pas encore ils n'ont pas encore
trouvé chaussure à leur pied
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que non
non je suis beaucoup de respect pour
roland dumas je voulais le dire
voilà et simplement non ce sont des
c'est une entreprise qui tue votre côté
asocial sa part dont dire que quand
roland cette chaîne c'est le passé
christine lamer qu'amr l'adulent quand
roland dumas dit le président république
peut plus être attaquée est vraiment aux
jeunes chirac peut pas être embêté sur
les hlm de paris
et quand roland dumas pour pas être
emmerdés sur elle fit donner chirac la
possibilité de pas être attaqué sur les
amériques par les hlm de paris vous vous
n'allez pas me dire qu'enfin franchement
c puis je vois bien un type comme vous
un type honnête comme vous ou alors puis
je vous répondre la répondez moi parce
que je serais curieux de connaître votre
lettre reçue
j'ai vu le dessin du monde où il serre
la main chirac et du marron se disant
merci
et vous que c'est la plus belle une du
monde que j'ai vu depuis longtemps
foutez moi je vais vous dire une chose
je n'ai jamais été en accord avec les
thèses du gouvernement que défendent et
roland dumas
je les ai combattu j'ai payé le prix
pour ça mais jusqu'à preuve du contraire
je crois que l'on peut combattre
quelqu'un en tout cas combattre les
idées de quelqu'un et le respecter bon
alors mis la faisait quelque chose à
jouer par rapport aux témoignages
sur scène à tour je trouve qu'il est
rare d'entendre quelqu'un dire
publiquement qu'il a de la sympathie que
roland dumas
moi j'en ai aussi beaucoup je suis
cependant d'accord avec vous sur le
conseil constitutionnel parce que je
trouve que ça peut vraiment un problème
de soupçonner à ce point la décision de
son conseil constitutionnel mais juste
sur la question roland dumas c'est
formidable quand même dans un pays comme
le nôtre à quel point un moment donné on
a le sentiment qu'on ne peut plus dire
du bien de quelqu'un ils ont
immédiatement être soupçonnée du pire
je suis absolument pour que cette
enquête ait jusqu'au bout et d'un autre
côté c'est vrai que je trouve formidable
pour puisse dire qu'on avait un
sympathique roland dumas parce que tout
c'est un type formidable
s'il a fait des choses que la loi
réprouve et bien qu'il soit puni mais
c'est quand même je vais vous laisser
quelqu'un qui passe quand même pas si
souvent que ça dans les médias lalanne
parce que dans l'ensemble à l'acheter
c'est quand même un moment donné de se
dire oh de toute façon je vais pas me
compromettre tout le monde tape ce
roland dumas je vais faire pareil très
bien ses vues s'est dit merci
djamel bouras alors oui j'avais déclaré
l'histoire qui ont une histoire qui
m'est arrivé c'est le cycliste djamel
bourras que c'est impossible c'est
djamel bouras vous avez déclaré c'est
une histoire à la omar m'a tuer ce qui
m'est arrivé à leur raconter nouveau
brièvement comment vous avez l'histoire
comment vous l'avez vécu dix ans très
bien mais apparemment vous avez un beau
sourire bien sûr malheureusement ouais
ce qu'on m'a toujours appris que
l'essentiel c'est de boire de manger de
respirer mais meehan omar m'a tuer parce
que j'ai suivi la dernière fois son son
histoire et c'est vraiment en plus quand
j'expliquais un peu ça c'est comme si
comme accusé d'un meurtre
disons aujourd'hui que je me retrouve en
inde où c'est vraiment et c'est ça le
pire c'est qu'on sait d'un côté
heureusement qu'on a les médias mais à
cause des médias
les gens qui savent que je suis innocent
n'ont pas voulu m'innocenter ce qu'ils
auraient perdu de la crédibilité
oui il ya un mot qu'on n'a pas utilisée
aussi c'est la mentalité c'est ça c'est
que en france il a une drôle de
mentalité et quand je parle de la france
il faut pas dire oui tu es français oui
je suis fier d'être français je suis
français mais on est on est de mauvaise
mentalité là ya des ministres qui est
arrivé et qui veut faire parler d'elle
je trouve
attendez moi le sel va finir par les
boues rouges suite à la non cet avis de
faire parce que c'est si je dis ça c'est
que c'est bien une autre vidéo c'est
bien sûr je suis un des premiers à
lutter contre le dopage contre le sport
mais il ya une façon de le faire c'est à
dire arriver en france
essayer de casser des cyclistes façon
que là vous expliquer par rapport la
mentalité c'est que dans le cyclisme
tous les français le savent que ça se
passe comme ça
les partenaires le savent le monde
entier le tout d'un coup soit disant on
sort un gros comme ça en voulant casser
tout le monde pourquoi en ce moment je
veux dire que sans dopage en prépa le
tour de france en vingt jours je sais
pas comment des faits nous devions sur
les juges
mais si on s'est moqué devient il faut
pas être faux cul parce qu'on sait que
tout se moquer de virac le chien faut
arrêter aussi sauf moi nous suivons
serait moqué c'est aussi parce que tu
sois envie de vous même où tout le monde
sait que tous les coureurs sont dopés
lors pourquoi urbain moquez vous de ce
qu'il faut ou des points contrairement à
tous les autres dit moi j'ai rien fait
la dirn on verra c'est là où il a fait
une connerie mais non mais quand il a
fait sa connerie lui la saq du tombe sur
la tête
donc c'est difficile quoi moi si j'avais
été à sa place je pense j'en sais rien
moi j'aurai tout dénoncer je m'en fous
moi je dénonce louvre mais c'est ça le
truc mais que que lui céline alors la
fois us
il a contrôlé il n'a pas eu cette force
ou foucher pas il a été mal conseillé
si on n'apportait vraiment dupe et au
seco l'heure que vous avez m
c'est vraiment ça on avait l'impression
il a raison doivent être pourvus jeu on
avait l'impression d'un gars au qui
était une marionnette avec un avocat qui
lui disait faut dire ça ça passe
ailleurs il a misé sur la mauvaise voie
maison vachement abuseurs trop trop
c'est trop il faut savoir s'excuser je
pense qu'ils ont été trop longs et
j'accueille maintenant il des médailles
d'or à g messieurs djamel bouras
alors donc djamel bouras médaille d'or
de judo aux jeux olympiques d'atlanta en
96 un an plus tard contrôlé positif à la
nandrolone
et vous parlez de ça dans un vent parler
donc dans un bouquin
m
on commence maintenant comment se
livrent d'ailleurs commence par
l'histoire de votre famille justement
votre grand père qui a fait 14 18
c'est pas mal de le dire ça je résume
les fois où est tout à fait en fait j'ai
voulu faire un je voulais raconter un
peu lieu d'où je venais ça va de mon
arbre un peu commencé et je crois que
c'est important surtout je voulais que
les français de souche parce que moi
j'ai une double culture
je voulais qu'on comprenne une fois pour
toute notre difficulté c'est qu'en fait
ils nous c'est à dire il nous disait
toujours qu'on est algérien
moi personnellement je suis né en france
mais mes parents nous et algériens on va
retourner définitif en algérie on n'est
pas chez nous ici je dis d'accord et
tout moi j'étais à la maison
bon c'est ça et lorsque j'arrivais
lorsque j'allais à l'école mon texte et
de quelle origine je suis algérien mais
était né en france c'est pas possible
bah à l'entrée on avait le cul entre
deux chaises convient donc il fallait
acheter le fallait trouver son canapé à
quel âge vous avez découvert le judo
puisque vous avez découvert le judo vous
dites je vis judo je dors judo je coure
judo je ne rêve que de combat et de
victoire 6 à quel âge ça j'ai commencé
le judo j'avais 8 ans et je pense que
c'est vers 12 13 ans c'est à dire que
même lorsque mon père disait bon bah
c'est d'école mois le judo ça ne
m'intéresse pas donc c'est l'école
lorsqu'il me donnait des livres et
fallait je lui résume les chapitres un
peu le soir j'étais là dans les bouquins
au bout d'une demi heure je me rends
compte j'avais
rien lu quoi j'étais dans un final
aux compétitions je ne sais pas 15 ans
notre première ceinture noire il est
même pas le droit de la porter puisque
j'ai du mal à 15 ans et 2 mois
d'apporter à 16 ans et en 88 ans assez
incroyable dans le genre patient 88 vous
voulez tellement participer au
championnat de france vous avez une
jambe cassée vous casser le plâtre ses
finances et je je je je me fais une
double honte ans arrachement du ligament
et jeu pour me mais le plâtre le soir
même et mon père qui me disaient non
nantes et le soir il a fallu que je
convaincs mon père pour qui le soir même
et mas sylvain enlevé mon plat tu sais
pas si le plâtre j'ai fait toute une
galère de rééducation avec le la lampe
qui me chauffe le pied le l'entraîneur
qui me masset qui me sinon pour moi là
je peins france était foot après vous
partez à joinville puisque beaucoup de
sportifs vont bataillon de joinville
pour faire l'armée est là justement
l'alcool vous permet vous buviez pas
évidemment en tant que musulmans chez
vous et l'alcool vous permet de faire
partie du groupe de vous intégrer un
petit peu avec les autres et c'est là
qu'a cette scène terrible 593 au japon
stage de de l'équipe de france après une
soirée arrosée vous avez un ami qui se
fait renverser par une voiture et qui
meurt le lendemain à l'hôpital juste il
avoue dit tous les deux avec avec lou ye
la main dans la main c'est que lorsque
je suis arrivé à j'avais 16-17 ans et
comme j'étais souvent dans ma cité là
bas on est toujours entre nous ils ont
toujours fait ça pour qu'on soit
toujours entre nous de façon lorsque je
suis arrivé là à paris ça a été une
ouverture pour moi mais lorsque j'arrive
j'étais toujours entouré de deux
français de souche ou à nous de
chrétiens qui pourraient l'alcool
n'était pas interdit quoi que ce soit et
moi je savais pas je croyais en mieux
mais bon j'étais pas pratiquants et donc
tout ça dès que les gens ont commencé à
boire moi j'étais au tour alors ça
rigolait pour pipi caca pour n'importe
quoi donc j'étais là toujours en dehors
je me dis je me faisais chier quoi
j'étais là ça alors je rentrais toujours
dans la chambre tout le temps tout le
temps j'étais un peu seule et puis à un
moment donné je me suis dit bon ben je
t'assure je pratique pas je vais faire
partie de leurs tripes quoi et jusqu'à
un moment où il ya eu cet accident au
japon et je regrette est rentré j'ai dit
je sais c'est de boire
j'ai étudié g après j'ai commencé à lire
des livres sur déjà je me suis posé la
question sur la croyance
merci à y at il un dieu ou pas donc j'ai
fait un peu des recherches personnelles
et puis ça aussi
c'est c'est notre coeur qu'il le sens et
pas vraiment aussi une ré la raison de
ce qu'on dit toujours que le coeur
dépasse la raison j'ai été le premier
musulman français donc champion
olympique en 96 et vous dédiez votre
médaille d'or au monde musulman ça a
choqué beaucoup de gens sachent que des
ouï mata sont l'ignorance choque
beaucoup de gens ce genre c'est pour ça
qu'on dit que l'ignorance engendre la
crainte et la crainte en jeunes et le
monde musulman c'est qu'il ya beaucoup
de choses qui nous laisse comme vécu
dans l'île c'est quelque chose qui
n'avait choqué certains musulmans
lorsque c'est à dire qu'on n'était pas
on est on ne jugeait pas de la même
façon lorsque c'était une autre personne
qui est musulman je donne un exemple au
liban et ont tué il ya eu je sais pas
104 morts et cette époque-là civile est
beaucoup moins de morts je me rappelle
en israël il ya eu quatre morts
on a donné 100 millions de dollars à
l'assemblée nationale ils ont fait une
minute de silence jeudi qu'elle c'est
super c'est beau ce qu'on fait enfin
comme dans le monde c'est extraordinaire
alors et ensuite il ya eu 104 civils
morts et la personne n'a rien fait ni
minute de silence et j'ai dit oui
pourquoi c'est comme ça et une autre
chose aussi qui m'a chaussée que ce qui
m'a choqué c'est que l'on bosnie avec ce
qui se passait ben parce qu'il n'y avait
pas de pétrole n'avait rien donc les
gens ne venaient pas là bas et en plus
il ya une autre chose ça si ça avait été
le contraire et j'en suis un peu
persuadé si ç'avait été les bosniaques
qui massacre les serbes on aurait dit à
les fous de dieu sont en train de
massacrer les pauvres chrétiens ou les
fruits et c'est ça que j'apprécie pas
c'est que sur les 1 milliard 300
millions de musulmans dans le monde il
suffit qu'il ya un petit pourcentage
d'ignorants et/ou de de fring dans tout
ce qu'on veut le monde musulman mais
beaucoup en exergue les les intégristes
et les fondamentalistes est-ce que ça
arrange beaucoup de monde c'est fait
c'est pour moi c'est fait exprès parce
que souvent les musulmans qu'on
interroge aussi on dirait qu'on l'ait
choisi parce qu'on a envie de montrer ça
il ya beaucoup de musulmans qui sont
très sages qui sont très très pieux qui
ont un respect de la femme qu'il n'est
même pas un européen
j'ai pas vu un européen amis européens
respecter sa femme comme ça et ça on ne
montre jamais avouer que c'est rare
djamel bouras que des musulmans
s'exprime à la télévision
en france pour parler de la religion jeu
à part le dimanche matin quand on dort
pourquoi parce que ouais on en met
d'accord parce que la pudeur ou ses
parties de wii ce qui se passe à sait
que c'est mal
dans la mentalité maintenant c'est mal
perçu lorsqu'on dit ouais je suis
musulman même ceux qui sont musulmans en
compte presque à dire que quand ils sont
tellement ils auront de dire boucher
musulman je fais le ramadan je fais 6 ha
bon parce que dès que tu dis ça ballon 3
hier à toi on se met un peu à l'écart va
qu'est ce qu'il va nous faire il va nous
taxer le rail pour les catholiques
maintenant quand quelqu'un dit je suis
catholique ont dit moi je vais être de
droite comme si être catholique je crois
toujours que je pense pas franchement
beaucoup moins peut-être un peu
maintenant mais beaucoup moins et c'est
dommage je trouve
[Applaudissements]
après notre après votre victoire
évidemment les médias se sont jetés sur
vous vous parlez de juppé qui vous
attendez vous êtes à regarder vous dit
qu'il était là qu'il était là pour se
faire mousser
c'est clair je veux dire pourquoi j'ai
dit pourquoi je dis ça parce que je le
pensais c'est à dire que tous les
sportifs déjà dans l'avion faisait ça
toi seront tellement les sportifs de la
fête à l'intérieur tout le monde est
arrivé les chemises déchirées torse nu
les ont même pas personne n'a vu juppé
mais ils sont là - les enfants
personne personne n'a fait attention pas
et puis ils sont là pour faire pour se
faire mousser
parce que donc dans mon épreuve les
preuves que j'ai eu
j'en ai tourné à toujours de façon mais
dans l'épreuve que j'ai eu c'est à dire
que lorsqu'on a besoin d'eux je parle
pas de jupe et pour toutes les
politiques
lorsque tu récites dext est un emblème
le commencement avec zidane tu vois ils
sont tous là si zidane il a besoin d'eux
ils sont là en garde à vue le dernier et
moi lorsque je les ai demain lorsque je
lui montre enfin lorsque je suis revenu
oui djamel alors y'a pas de problème est
que ce seras tu vois comme tu de ta
famille tu viens tout ce que tu veux tu
vois et quand j'ai mon problème excusez
moi mais je
je suis innocent il ya vraiment une
injustice est en train de se passer et
c'était rage
oui vous savez les pales en afrique là
ils sont pas là toi c'est pas ça c'est
sans doute ce qui nous a c'est tout ce
qui nous a réunis puis comme j'ai un peu
plus de bouteille du temps à ça c'est
clair
j'ai lu je ne suis permis de lui dire
qu'il fallait peut-être avoir un peu
plus de recul parce que c'est très
difficile pour quelqu'un comme duhamel
qui a été touchée aussi je voudrais
juste si c'est possible que tu montres
tes mains armées droite et doit monter
voir parce que voyez pour pour être
champion olympique il a déformé ses
mains et regarder comment sont faits les
doigts et donc quand on souffre comme ça
pour être champion olympique on a
attaqué il ya deux façons de réagir et
c'est vrai et je parle sous le contrôle
de jamel c'est vrai que par rapport à
ses origines par rapport à ce qu'il a il
avait peut-être plutôt tendance à se
réfugier dans la haine plutôt que
tourner la page et de démontrer
seulement qu'il était le plus fort et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui il a devant soi
quelqu'un qui font alors
[Applaudissements]
donc quand vous avez gagné cette
médaille faisait beaucoup de succès donc
évidemment juppé qui vous attend experts
vous le regardez même pas élu cinéma
vous tombe dessus
c'est un peu la même histoire que
florent pagny vous êtes tombé sur
dominique besnehard way et je vais
rencontrer avant d'être avant d'être
avant de reproposer des rôles de
maghrébins beau gosse amoureux d'une
bourgeoise avec des scènes d'amour si
vous n'êtes pas branché on a proposé une
dizaine là depuis on m'a proposé une
fois un scénar alors c'était soi disant
voilà maghrébins qui habite dans un
village qui sort avec toutes les filles
et la tombe tombe amoureux d'une fille
du front national superbe le midi on va
proposer un autre je vous en donne un
autre le deuxième c'est le travail je
suis fait livreur chez pizza etc
et puis je tombe dans un jeu dans une
banque je me retrouve avec une
bourgeoise et puis on a enchaîné tous
les deux et puis après on se retrouve on
avoue que des pions que les premiers
rôles en plus ou moins pour un début
c'est super vous avez la légion
d'honneur brûlez pas refuser les gens
d'honneur pas parce que
en commandant fils de chanter la
marseillaise pour commandes il faut
tremblay pour grandir et puis à cette
époque là quand tu es un peu dans les
nuages tu fais pas gaffe à plein de
choses et puis bon jeu déjà que tu as et
robben comme ça je me suis dit bon si
déjà en 96 j'ai dis j'essaie de dire
beaucoup de choses
alors si je me suis dit je me fais
remarquer encore pour ça et loyalement
savent à cela une mais ça valait bien
sympa mais et c'est pour ça mais c'est
vrai que la mecque réflexion je me dis
mais pourquoi je l'accepté pour moi ça
ça a rien une légende ou meurs je sais
pas quand j'ai appelés quand j'ai
appelés quand j'ai mon problème sa
personne n'a mentionné arrive à vos
problèmes et un chapitre dans gothic
s'appelle heure là on dirait du beau
temps lors des trahisons et vous dites
les amis du champion olympique ont du
mal à être ceux du dopé ma chance dans
tout ça c'est que je fais du sport de
combat dont la rue les gens disent pas
on va lui dire tu iras tu es doc et
aussi parce que les énoncés jamais si si
bien peu fait d'études
tu vois donc ça déjà ça m'a sauvé un peu
mais le plus plus il m'a touché c'est ma
famille ça lorsqu'on a une petite soeur
qui est ferment qui est magnifique à 12
ans et qui va à l'école
nissan qui a dit ça qui revient en
pleurant qui parle d'école parce que tu
as tous ses copains de c'est
compréhensible en plus à cet âge-là 300
à 12 13 ans on est toujours un peu vache
et vise oui ton frère c'est un tricheur
ou quoi que ce soit qui revient en
pleurant qui va pas à l'école pendant le
temps et où enfin ma mère les douleurs
qu'elle a parce que même si je veux
avoir maintenant 25 28 ans je serai
toujours son bébé quoi et lorsqu'il ya
un problème et ses amis là bon quand ils
m'ont appelé m'ont pas dit mais qu'est
ce que tu as fait me rappelait mon mimi
qu'est ce qu'ils t'ont fait est ce qui
s'est passé et cette fois cette fois là
j'ai ma famille vous savez nous quand on
compte on jure peut-être qu'elle
n'entrait pas que ça ne veut plus rien
dire quand on jure sur quelque chose on
est obligé de nous croire ça sent que
moi j'ai d'aider la médaille d'or vaut
une langue qui se disent les musulmans
lorsque je quand je suis arrivé là bas
qu'en chute de 100 m du bord je leur ai
dit tout simplement parce que j'ai une
fille qui s'appelle inès et j'aurais dit
que dieu aujourd'hui me maudissent moi
ma fille ma famille si moi j'ai fait ça
ils sont mis à pleurer en france parce
qu'ils savent de quoi je parle
tu vois ça fait quand même une
c'était assez grave c'est assez fort que
je voudrais soyez thierry jam elle vit
quelque chose que tous les gens qui ont
été condamnés à un moment vive
il est aujourd'hui blanchi et pourtant
voulu reposer des questions sur son
passé et continue à y répondre
tu dois plus répondre à cette question
djamen parce qu'on t'a rendu sa médaille
donc ça n'a plus lieu d'être tournage
[Applaudissements]
comme moi
aujourd'hui j'ai appris une bonne chose
c'est que je vais l'amener à chaque fois
dans les émissions de cendre à l'abri
travers la lumière n'est pas terminé il
ya sydney je dédierai ma victoire à tous
les djamel bouras de cette terre ça va
quand même temps s'ils ne la signale des
envies mois septembre
cet homme si je le fais deux faces je
serai le seul français à l'avoir fait on
quand il fut alors là je sais plus ce
qu'ils vont faire
j'espère je leur demande juste une sauce
est de ne rien faire ne rien faire avant
pour que je puisse y aller mais
voilà merci à toi c'est et puis voilà
quoi mais si djamel bouras
bon ça va djamen bien souvent alors
djamel bouras bas médaille d'or atlanta
on l'a dit retour triomphal en france
après atlanta vous êtes un peu à
l'époque le symbole zidane est ce que de
l'intégration dire regardez les lui la
france est formidable et que des beurs
qui gagne au foot et qui gagne au judo
et puis en 97 vous êtes contrôlés
positifs à la nandrolone est suspendu un
an
mais le doute subsiste malgré tout parce
que vous d'abord voulu nier et le doute
subsiste alors 11d plusieurs hypothèses
qui sont échafaudés à ce moment là
est-ce que vous secret était
naturellement de la nandrolone parce
qu'il faut savoir quand même que tout ça
c'est des mesures sur cinq millionième
de gramme
deuxième hypothèse la fiabilité des
mesures parce que c'est vrai qu'en 1 5
millionième de gramme ce n'est pas tout
les balances qui peuvent le mesurer et
puis la deuxième solution c'est le
produit vous auriez pris un produit non
interdite qui aurait les mêmes effets
dans les contrôles que la nandrolone en
fin bon dans tous les cas on n'a jamais
su c'est ce qu'ils m'ont proposé de dire
c'est ce qui vous en proposer des oui et
j'ai refusé
mais bon j'aimerais bien voir le même
les même jusqu'à lui virenque
ouais parce que ça faisait deux ans
qu'il disait qu'il était innocent ouais
et il a balancé en disant qu'il avait
pris part et moi aussi j'ai ses juges
comme ils ont été acquises en l'air très
compétent ouais donc moi je veux bien
avoir ces juges là pour qu'il me juge et
moi je signe un papier aujourd'hui que
si demain je dis que j'ai pris si
j'arrive à trouver quelque chose je fais
une signe pour aller pour faire 15 ans
de prison
mais quand vous vous dites que nous dira
que ça fait plusieurs années qu'il nie
bon un jour il avoue il va prendre six
mois
vous vous dites moi j'ai toujours aimé
les ondes en un an ferme
voilà donc 16 mois sans compétition dont
vous êtes prêt 1.15 on trouve que c'est
vrai retrouvez les en colombie un peu de
partout pour aller faire des ventes de
passer devant les jurés j'ai perdu pas
mal d'argent
c'est pas grave ça c'est mon chemin dans
dans la vérité j'essaye mais j'aimerais
bien avoir ce mur et je la fais
j'appelle se jurait venez chercher de la
vérité vous allez savoir j'ai rien fait
vous dit si je suis coupable je suis
prêt à prendre 15 ans 15 ans et tout le
bien que je vous le donne ouais je suis
devant vous pas de problème alors oui
donc en 99 des suspendus par la
fédération internationale dont quinze
mois loin des tatamis vous
retournez vous revenez dans le judo avec
des résultats un peu en dents de scie et
à sydney vous partez à sydney alors vous
étiez dans quel état d'esprit parce que
moi j'ai lu une déclaration vous avez
fait je crois que c'est dans les kivu
dit en parlant de sydney je ne suis pas
venu défendre un titre olympique c'est
pas comme le championnat du monde où la
boxe
les jeux ont en effet une fois dans sa
vie puis moi j'ai gagné le titre et
c'est pour toujours
c'est dans l'équipe du 19 septembre
serre que vous en faites est ce qu'on
peut pas vous reprocher finalement les
traits dessinés en disant moi j'ai été
champion olympique une foire c'est
formidable après tout maintenant c'est
du bonus quoi parce que toute façon j'ai
été champion olympique est ce que vous
n'êtes pas parti à signer en disant que
le vrai combat c'était celui d'atlanta
et que si venait c'était du bonus mais
c'était pas fondamental pour vous non
parce que si c'est ça j'arrête je suis
plus motivé
ouais je crois que l'on fût ce avec ce
qui s'est passé j'avais une autre
motivation
donc j'avais eu envie de gagner mais bon
il y avait des jeux comme j'ai eu pas
mal de problèmes et puis comme j'ai des
problèmes avec l'arbitrage depuis deux
ans vous dites avoir été meilleur à
sydney
qu'atlanta et pourtant vous avez perdu
mais j'étais le meilleur
c'est à dire que le combat que j'ai fait
là bas qui était beaucoup un peu moins
dur à atlanta que j'ai gagné de justesse
alors que là les combats j'ai commencé
par un premier combat qui aurait pu être
une finale déjà contre à rennes
le landais et que je me l'arbitrage
c'était contre moi et j'ai gagné quand
même par ippon réponse est l'arrêt darré
du combat et des trois premiers combats
je les ai gagnés par ippon j'avais un
tirage très dans mon quart de finale
c'était le quart de finale le plus dur
et je suis arrivé en demi finale contre
le japonais s'était tu dis que tu
méritais le monter sur le podium
c'est à dire qu'en demi finale si je
gagne en finale ouais donc voilà je
prends le coroner le coréen du nord en
finale que j'ai battu et on à paris
alors là dedans maintenant mais où on
est au coeur du problème donc vous dites
et c'est important parce que ce n'est
pas moi qui disais ça vous n'êtes pas le
seul à le dire
vous dites depuis c'est la faute des
arbitres si j'ai pas été sur le podium à
sydney depuis les androphones je suis
plus jugé comme les autres et là j'ai
relevé un certain nombre d'avis de de
gens importants qu'ils disent la même
chose que vous donc là ça pose vraiment
problème et ça mérite qu'on s'y
intéresse
il ya jean luc rougé qui est directeur
de la fédé qui dit
ce mérite pas c'est une sanction contre
contre bouras fabien canu qui est
directeur technique national qui dit on
ne veut pas qu'ils gagnent donc les mecs
c'est pas des importe qui 1
il ya michel vial qui est chef de la
mission française aux jo de sydney qui
dit c'est malhonnête
il a payé et on veut quand même
continuer à le pousser dehors
voilà quoi donc il ya quand même un
service que les gens vous savez j'ai
regardé les arbitres et b s'est un peu
tous la tête je vais dire écoutez
maintenant si c'est ça que vous voulez
je vais arrêter
voilà donc vous aujourd'hui non
seulement vous mais encore si vous vous
le disiez on pourrait dire il est parano
il n'a pas gagné il cherche des excuses
mais il se trouve quand même que les
sommités du judo dans ce pays
les sommités officiels disent en fait
c'est vrai djamel bouras n'est pas jugée
comme il devrait être jugé t on veut le
virer quoi déjà un championnat d'europe
ou trois quatre mois avant je me suis
fait voler contre le biélorusse les
arbitres ont reconnu donc ils sont venus
une excuse excusez moi on sait on
s'excuse format compact elle est finie
quoi même maintenant six excuses n ont
pas refaire les jo pour narrer tu t'es
fait couler par un biélorusse
le fait que vous revendiquez votre
islamisme est ce que vous pensez pas que
ça peut aussi jouer contre vous qu'est
ce que ça veut dire islamisme non mais
vous êtes musulman vous le revendiquez
machy catholique je me revendique c'est
mal joué et tout à fait les gros titres
les gros titres mais dactique français
lorsque je vois ça quand on parle
d'islamisme c'est un peu avec
l'intégrisme
lorsqu'on est de confession musulmane
lorsqu'on est français de confession
musulmane est con on dédie sa médaille
d'or parce qu'elle est injuste
il ya eu des injustices cette année-là
envers les musulmans
et donc j'ai été touché quand je vois
qu'il y avait des oppresseurs et des
opprimés et que ya pas de justice qui se
faisait massacrer parce qu'il n'y avait
pas de livres pétrole a gagné n'y a rien
du tout c'est normal que je dédie un peu
ma médaille d'or un peu j'ai une pensé à
vous savez je le regarde pas du tout si
c'était à refaire je l'aurais refait
alors j'ai reçu beaucoup de mails
la suite de l'intervention dans
l'émission de michel boujenah d'abord
pour me demande ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que michel boujenah a été invité
ici pour parler de son spectacle il est
arrivé un peu cassée et d'une panne
d'électricité s'est assis là il nous a
parlé de son spectacle et ce n'était pas
du tout prévu que michel boujenah
s'exprime sur le problème du
moyen-orient sur le conflit israélo
arabe
il a dit son opposition à lui
dans l'émission et j'ai reçu beaucoup
beaucoup d'e mail me disant si la france
veut montrer ça la véritable neutralité
française dans le conflit du
moyen-orient
il faut que vous invitiez la semaine
prochaine quelqu'un qui est musulman
alors je profite de votre présence ici
djamel bouras pour vous demander si vous
avez vu le intervention de boujenah mais
pour ceux qui ne l'ont pas vu on va la
regarder mais quand je vois des enfants
en première ligne avec derrière eux des
palestiniens armés et devant eux
dernière mais et que je vois les enfants
au milieu avec les pierres jeudi qui
sont les parents de ces enfants qui ont
9 10 ans pour qui les laisse sortir
comment un père peut laisser son fils de
neuf ou dix ans sortir pour jeter des
pierres
alors qui sait ce qu'ils risquent le
soldat qui en face il a 18 ans qu'est ce
que voulez qu'il fasse
vous croyez qu'il va pas porté toute sa
vie la mort de l'enfant voudrait que
toute sa vie va pas le regretter
c'est trop simple ce qui se passe en
france aujourd'hui et la désinformation
qui a eu est extraordinaire dans les
idées je dire informer nous c'est ya pas
longtemps il ya eu 3 3 liseré l'un qui
ont été lynchées lyncher ça veut dire
c'est pas je me bats avec toi et je te
tue ça veut dire je te prends je tâte h
et je te pend c'est pas la même chose il
faut les jeux ce que je ressens
aujourd'hui par rapport à ce qui se
passe en france sur les synagogues qui
ont été brûlés sur toute la résurgence
de cette violence qui vient en france
je pense que la presse et les médias ont
une grande responsabilité
vous avez un pouvoir un pouvoir qui est
dangereux qu'il faut manipuler avec
beaucoup de délicatesse et beaucoup
d'intelligence
je crois qu'il ya une l'egypte
mythe et il ya quelque chose qui a
légitimé cette violence chez les jeunes
ici en france qui est illogique qui est
folle il ya bien beaucoup de victimes
dans cette histoire
chez les palestiniens et chez les
isréliens faut pas l'oublier quand j'ai
bu un palestinien la télé il ya deux
jours qui a perdu un fils ça me fait de
la peine de voir un homme père de son
fils créer moi j'ai un enfant je sais ce
que c'est il qu'est ce qu'il a dit là
dit j'en ai encore quatre à sacrifier
jeunes encore 4 il n'a pas dit je vais
aller me battre mois il a dit j'ai
encore quatre à sacrifier voilà c'était
donc michel boujenah dans la dernière
émission de tout le monde en parle donc
comme je les dis ils venaient pour
parler de son spectacle à un moment la
conversation est venu là dessus
effectivement beaucoup de gens m'ont dit
pourquoi on donne pas la parole à ceux
qui sont en face ben voilà vous pouvez
vous exprimer
djamel bouras je crois que le point le
plus important du discours de michel
boujenah c'est de dire c'est pas bien
envoyer des enfants quoi parce que
effectivement c'est jouer à travers la
télévision entre les médias s'est joué à
travers la sur la sensibilité des gens
mais je pense qu'il ya un peu pas mal de
d'ignorance de sa part premièrement et
déjà j'aimerais enlever des amalgames
quand il parle de médias déjà on va voir
tout de suite sur le point aujourd'hui
fin de cette semaine
qu'est ce que veut dire pour moi je ne
comprends pas moi je suis un peu bête
les juifs français les arabes
c'est à dire que moi je suis quoi arabes
ou juifs français pourtant je combats
pour la france je m'en passe pendant que
ya beaucoup de français en plus s'il
faut savoir que quand on dit antisémite
les arabes sont des sémites ou si nos
missions plus antisioniste antisémite
voulait dire voilà tout à fait dans
cette voie il ya beaucoup de choses qui
sont différents n'arrête pas de faire
des amalgames seront entre les arabes
les musulmans et des arbres qui sont
retirés des arbres qui sont hâtés exedra
qui sont etc etc
donc ça c'est une chose très importante
ensuite je vais répondre un peu je vais
essayer de répondre un peu à boujenah je
crois qu'il a eu des problèmes un peu
avec son spectacle parce qu'il a dit
autre chose et déjà il ya deux semaines
sur le jdd
j'étais surpris un peu délicat c'est
super qu'il a dit il est que sharon
c'était un [ __ ] presse etc etc et
dates de semaine après échange de
discours
sachant que ça rentre c'est vraiment un
[ __ ] faux pas il faut pas oublier d
massacre qui l'afer au liban et ses bras
et chatila avec 1500 morts etc etc
un bon en plus ce qu'il faut le problème
de la bande israël sait qu'il ya des
résolutions par l'onu qui ont été faites
celles de la la la résolution de 67 je
crois qu'elle à 2 242 ils sont dans des
territoires occupés il devrait partir
c'est l'onu qui a décidé ça ils ne
partent pas ensuite on parle quand il
parle des enfants
de quel enfant et par lequel l'enfant il
parle des enfants mais maintenant qu'ils
sont devant lui un char non mais des
enfants nés ici avec leurs chocolats
leur pain chaud que le croissant et
c'est là nintendo etc
des gens qui sont nés dans la guerre
convient leurs pères mais leur père
mourir ils ont même pu de pair pour le
redis reste ici les ont plus de mer ils
mangent pas c'est une catastrophe
il faut aller voir moi je le prends mon
moi je aujourd'hui je suis là pareil je
suis pas là à faire le justicier de la
terre 1
mais il ya des choses qui me révolte
donc moi je le prends moi - boujenah on
va prendre une caméra et demain je pars
avec lui là bas on va filmer
comment vit israël commet et israël et
on va filmer comment vivent les
palestiniens et je crois que cette
vérité va faire beaucoup de mal parce
que je vous assure que ces gens
souffrent on croyait qu'il serait pas
mieux à notre place en train de jouer en
train de faire en train de sortir avec
des petites filles en train de s'amuser
comme tout le monde
non il s'entraînera en pratique et quand
on dit mais l'enfant oui mais l'enfant
croyait que le jeune quand il dit les
massacres les trois soldats qui ont été
massacrés mais c'est des soldats et
quand on me dit se sont trompés de
terrain en tant que guerre tu vas te
tromper terrain tu te retrouve chez les
palestiniens
mais ça fout la raconter sa vie à des
enfants ou des jeunes n'est pas tout le
monde quand même il faut pas nous
prendre pour des cons savez israël il ya
pas que des juifs
des arabes il ya donc il est quoi
exactement
il est tunisien il est français qui ne
viseraient je sais pas il faudrait
qu'ils m'expliquent un peu une personne
comme une reine comme assia qui a chanté
une chanson sur le malheur à celui qui
qui qui touche un enfant
malheur à celui qui touche un enfant
elle veut bien dire ce que ça veut dire
qu'il soit noir ou blanc et c'est alors
et quand tu le vois défiler sur les
champs elysées pour avec des drapeaux je
sais pas si c'était lui ou pam avait des
drapeaux et des sionistes on est fiers
et c est que tu le vois après d'irm
alors c'était quoi c'était un business
et que moi je les vis j'étais avec lui
quand j'étais invité par là comme j'ai
une double culture j'étais invité par le
président bouteflika
je les ai vus en train de pleurer et
pourra pas nier sa vie en train de
pleurer devant boudant bouteflika en
train de dire h monde mon pays l'algérie
je suis fier je suis fier je veux
rentrer là bas etc
il a fait une chanson fessenheim comme
ainsi atteindre est comme ça je me dis
mais attend dans ma tête je me dis donc
c'est quoi ce jeu là sans quoi c'est
quoi comme citoyen c'est quoi comme ils
sont algériens ils sont français ils
sont israéliens c'est quoi le truc
moment donné je crois que on est tous
pour la paix moi je suis le premier à
être pour la paix pour l'amour pour tous
ces mots là qui nous entourent qu'on a
envie de 2 pour lesquelles on a envie de
vivre et moi je suis un des premiers
mois je suis contre les gens qui brûlent
des synagogues mais déjà il faut être
sûr que ce soit des français d'origine
maghrébine etc avant de dénoncer quoi
que ce soit quelle est votre position où
il avait vite bbl là dessus bah moi on
en parlait tout à l'heure
moi je crois que émigré pour parler des
français d'origine
arabes afin qu'ils sont musulmans mais
qui sont français ou des juifs français
pour moi et me grey s'est pas changé
deux pays s'échangent et d'histoire
l'idée quand même 2 quand on est
français juifs français arabe français
on est français
moi je me souviens d'avoir inauguré la
mosquée de lyon avec charles pasqua
quand il était à l'intérieur
j'ai un petit peu puisque elle a
participé à la rédaction du discours qui
à l'inauguration la mosquée millions 94
je m'en souviens bien héhéhé c'était ça
l'idée c'était le même sang versé pour
la même patrie au fond l'a été par des
gens d'origines très différentes et au
fond c'est pour les immigrés c'est
changer d'histoire
si vous êtes français vous êtes français
d origine m algérienne qui pouvait être
tunisiennes peuvent être en ce qui me
concerne j'en ai des croates j'en ai les
russes j'en ai j'en ai j'en ai d'autres
encore
même mon histoire elle commence avec
l'histoire de france et justement
l'intégrer si on prend l'exemple de
l'irak
lorsque en 91 le 17 janvier ils ont mis
un ultimatum ce jour là ils ont dit
voilà il ya une résolution vous devez
partir du koweit non on n'est pas
d'accord
le monde entier et est contre eux ont
bombardé et je vous expliquais un truc
si vous ne savez pas il ya 7000 enfants
par mois qui mord encore là ils sont en
train de se faire bombarder encore et
personne ne veut 7000 7000 enfants par
mois qui mord et je vous explique anne
au dessus si vous savez pas ils vendent
leurs organes pour manger des choses
qu'on sait jamais mais ça fait dix ans
qu'ils sont quand on leur donne pas à
manger ils ont même pas le droit d'avoir
des crayons à papier parce qu'ils ont
peur s'ils vont construire de larmes
chez désarmement chimiques etc
c'est une catastrophe c'est une
catastrophe ce que vous dites djamel
bouras et lorsque l'irak au koweït ne
respecte pas une décision de l'onu
le monde entier se coalisent pour faire
respecter les décisions de l'onu sur sur
israël la palestine ni à une décision de
l'onu que la résolution 242 7 chiffres
et vous dites que personne se coalisent
pour la faire respecter la soeur parce
que israël est protégé par le grand
patron du monde est le grand patron du
monde et les états unis et est
subventionné par les états unis
les liens la vie morale c'est exact ça
c'est tout à fait là où se trouve dans
cette histoire encore qui
absurde c'est que tout le monde au début
de cette histoire lorsque sharon est
allé sur l'esplanade
je sais pas ce qu'il allait faire ce
jour là ils allaient faire taire sa
prière il était alex ans avec 100 il est
devenu avec 100 supporters snipers
c'est pas des supporters c'est des
snipers enfin bref il est venu juste
parce qu'il allait faire les gens tout
le monde a dit ils ont tort la seule le
seul état qui s'est abstenu c'est quand
même les américains bien mais je
rappelle le titre de votre livre combat
vers la lumière
vous étiez venu à l'époque où c'était
sorti donc j'avais leur âge vous étiez 5
mai dernier à la manif contre la loi sur
le voile à l'école car vous êtes contre
il faut bien le dire vous dit si on
exclut ces jeunes filles voilées de
l'école laïque
elles vont devenir encore moins laïque
est effectivement sur les renvoyer chez
elles elles vont être encore plus
musulmane disons je crois que il faut
laisser la liberté à chacun il ya qu'en
france en ce moment où on pose toutes
ces questions moi qui ai l'habitude de
voyager par le sport ou par autres
j'entends y a qu'en france où j'entends
ces choses là maintenant aussi
j'aimerais expliquer aux gens que j'ai
participé à cette manifestion cette
manifestation en tant qu'individu la
société civile parce que je suis quand
j'entends des choses qui me choquent là
je suis un peu mais ni temps depuis que
je suis enfant et quand il ya des choses
qui me choquent la preuve
56e le pen qui est passé second tour on
sait de manifester parce qu'il y avait
un acte une personne raciste qu'elle est
passée au faux bond
enfin bref ce sera son chrono
c'est un deux voiles d'accord mais tu
parles pas de jean-marie comme pour moi
la chose la plus importante c'est le
savoir et la connaissance
donc à partir du moment où tu enlèves
les gens l'école c'est à dire que même
si on est dans l'erreur
ouais tu vas l'école était dans l'erreur
bond honte à vous allez et c'est à toi
décolleté par an sur intégristes ou je
ne sais pas tu vas l'école mais s'ils
ont pu sont enlève de ça on t'enlève
l'école pour pouvoir tout mélanger et
échanger avec des ouf comme ça enfin de
partout tu peux ouvrir ou à prendre
ben tu vas tu vas donc je vois pas où
c'est que tu peux tu vas devenir encore
plus renfermés sur toi mais exactement
fondamentale pour moi la chose la plus
importante c'est de là l'accès aux
savoirs et de savoir et la connaissance
alors vous dites que finalement le port
du voile peut effectivement peut-être
perturber la scolarité mais moins qu'un
string qui dépasse d'un jean non je
plaisante est pas ce que j'ai entendu
des gamins diabaté à la télé et ça
m'avait fait rire qui disait que un peu
comme dans son style disait qu'ils
étaient venus des rangs dérangé par un
string quand il était à l'école qui
dépassait du jeans que par un foulard
l'afrique le foulard personnes à calcul
alors que la fille quand en classe et un
bon qu est l acte ce stent et plus
déconcentrer car ça que par le truc cool
en main vous allez vous êtes ce que vous
êtes contre le port du string à l'école
non moi je suis pas pour moi chacun fait
ce qu'il veut
le board et deux en même temps djamel
vous vous jugé que cette loi faisait nos
folles imbécile et raciste évite au
gouvernement est en train d'installer
l'islamophobie dans ce pays
la preuve hier ils ont commencé à dire
que la barbe il fallait pas la barbarie
et le bandana tel bandana vrai nom mais
deviennent de plus en plus diola alors
vous étiez à cette manifestation donc
samedi le problème c'est que d'abord
c'est bon pour le pen c'est à dire que
quand les français voient au journal
télévisé tous et tous ces gens qui
cherchent ils vous pensez bien que ça va
faire des voix en plus pour le pen seule
manifestation vous savez très bien et
l'autre problème c'est aussi que
beaucoup de députés de droite à
commencer par balladur qui étaient
d'accord pour ne pas voter la loi il
disait finalement oui cette fois ça sert
à rien depuis la manifestation de sa
mise en changer d'avis son envie de la
beauté que vous pensez pas que ce genre
de manifestation
à quelques mois des élections peut
finalement de provoquer un raidissement
de la classe politique française
moi je pense oui ouais ouais je pense
quoi assouvir et les manifs je pense que
le grand gagnant pas de la manif
parce que ya pas que ça fait ça fait
quelques temps quand même que
l'événement
ouais que couvre couvre les médias quoi
donc c'est pas une question de manifs ou
pas de manif ça depuis très longtemps on
en parle maintenant je pense que cette
politique la mènera alors je crois que
c'est pas bon à cette manifestation il y
avait aussi mohamed latrèche du pmf le
parti des musulmans de france alors lui
les antisionistes bon ça c'est son droit
il est aussi terriblement antisémite il
est l'éditeur du manifeste judéo nazis
d'ariel sharon qui est une vraie fausse
interview du premier ministre d'israël
il était à la tribune avec serge thion
qui était un négationniste très connu et
il a dit en parlant de serge thion je
suis très content et fier de le
connaître est ce que à un moment
finalement même si vous n'étiez pas
derrière lui on a bien compris mais est
ce qu'à un moment le fait finalement de
manifester avec quelqu'un comme la
trèche c'est pas dangereux
maintenant mais moi comme je dis c'est
un ami sic au début qui est venu dans
mon salon et qu'il me dise
manifestent samedi jeudi pour 7 contre
cette loi je dis bah écoute c'est super
moi aussi je suis contre cette tendance
et après dans les médias j'entendais
tous les jours comme quoi il y avait un
espèce de groupe
enfin partis politiques et m qu'est ce
que c'est que ce truc là personne ne
connait on le connaît même pas ouais et
donc je suis allé en tant qu'observateur
pour montrer que j'étais content c'est
là que vous avez dit je suis d'aucune
mouvance vous l'avez déclaré je viens
tous les états ni quand j'ai entendu
parler
cette personne me suis sauvée ouais
ouais ouais mais c'est vrai qu'à cette
manif on aurait préféré voir monseigneur
lustiger
hologram industries mais c'est moi c'est
ça j'ai cru qu'elle veut ça j'ai cru
qu'ils avaient tout le monde quoi
c'est quand même une loi raciste quoi
vous vous savez quand même que vous êtes
en train de devenir le porte parole des
musulmans c'est parce que ça il en
faudra bien tout va mais dans tous les
pays du monde et des gens qui sont un
moment porté porté sur le deuxième c'est
que les gens les des gens qui n'osent
pas parler et moi ça va et chekwa ya des
gens qui pensent qu'à leur business voix
alors que un moment donné on se fait
insulter tout le temps j'ai ramené un
petit manifeste ici tous les jours tu
vois on est quand même des musulmans
chacun a sa demie à sa l'unité tu vas
bien sûr et puis un proverbe qui dit
valérie la dignité en enfer s'il le faut
ils refusent l'humiliation même au
paradis
ouais qe2 moutanabi ça et quand tu
entends un mec comme claude imbert
claude amer qui dit je suis un peu
islamophobe
ça ne gêne pas de le dire j'ai le droit
de penser que l'islam
je dis bien l'islam je ne parle même pas
des islamistes apporte une certaine dit
bilité qui en effet me rends islamophobe
et ça c'est un bear qu'entend quand tu
entends les réalistes au journal le
point oui bien sûr quand tu entends
houellebecq qui dit la religion à
houellebecq la religion la plus con
c'est quand même l'islam quand on lit le
coran en effondré il faut admettre une
chose doit évidemment je suis catholique
mais en même temps en france de tous
temps il ya des gens confié sur la
religion catholique et on a appris à
vivre avec ça fait partie de la
démocratie ça non ouais ça fait partie
de la zone sud sud moi je veux dire
quand je vois le pin pon guignols qui
prend de la coke par exemple ça me gêne
mais voilà c'est comme ça ils ont le
droit de le faire un moment
non mais je dis pas qu'on n'a pas droit
de le faire mais de dire des conneries
concerne un ministre quand il est commis
qui plaisantent là-dessus encore
compréhensible mais quand c'est un
ministre qui dit xavier darcos qui dit
content quand on n'aime pas la
république française on va ailleurs à la
france aimez là ou quittez là c'est à
dire que quand t'es pas content se
permettre c'est toi
mais ce qui s'est passé que ses chansons
françaises le problème c'est qu'on
n'accepte pas la preuve
la preuve c'est que comment un ministre
le ministre le premier ministre de
l'intérieur sarkozy qui soit disant pas
de deux républiques quoi nicolas 8es
contre la loi et finalement il s'est
rallié s'il va demander ça veut dire
qu'il va demander son avis à l'étranger
ouais c'est à dire qu'il va y va il va
en egypte pour demander à soi disant
chère savants religieux pour le dire est
ce que j'ai le droit quand même de faire
ça ça veut dire qu il alors que c'est un
problème franco français
le rsc bien que le cas de prendre la vie
des des sommités musulmanes dans le
monde 7e minute et on le connaît pas on
n'est pas de ce mythe et c'est à dire ça
c'est un problème franco français je
vois pas pourquoi ça veut dire que nous
acceptons pas encore comprends qu'on
n'est pas comme français en france c'est
ça le problème
mais il ya un autre qui a pourtant s'il
te plait je devrais te dire c'est moi
j'ai fait les jeux olympiques tu vas
j'ai rapporté des médailles pour la
france et pour il ya des valeurs que
j'ai représenté
mais ces valeurs là quand j'ai lu cet
article à cette déclaration c'est ça que
j'ai défendue alors j'aimerais
j'aimerais vous lire cette déclaration
qui dit qui dégradent yankees djamel des
glaçons des droits universels des droits
de l'homme basé chez claire c'est à dire
que même les lois qu'on fait les
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme c'est au dessus
c'est vrai d'accord non il faut bien
écouter je la porte l'attention de hao
genre tu vas bien écouter cette
déclaration qui dit toute personne a
droit à la liberté de pensée de
conscience et de religion ce droit
implique la liberté de manifester sa
religion ou sa conviction seule ou en
commun tant en public qu'en privé par le
lez par l'enseignement les pratiques le
culte et l'accomplissement des rites
c'est clair non donc je sais pas ce
qu'on essaie en fait ça c'est l'arbre
qui cache la forêt la france a beaucoup
de problèmes en ce moment au niveau
chômage
au niveau il ya 30 dans les sociétés il
ya un moment il ya plein de problèmes
sauf qu'on mette une histoire du voile
ça va clasher tous les problèmes qu'on a
c'est un peu que tu penses chaussures de
roland dumas sur l' affaire des frégates
de taïwan quoi way serait pas bien son
histoire
ce jour là connaître une corrélation non
mais bon tu va donc continuer à
manifester quand tu l'as me fais ce que
je veux continuer de la maturité tout le
temps mais maintenant on va essayer de
ne pas se faire piéger par certains mais
c'est clair que non parce que si c'est
si ça avait été les juifs qui veut la
paix les kings djamel on va enlever nos
trucs je vais avec eux mais manifester
j'accueille max gallo
salomon soir on savait que anh dao
traxel est la fille la troisième fille
de jacques chirac notre président de la
république voilà et valérie demain à
essayer de faire un livre au sujet de
cécilia sarkozy livre le livre qu'ils ne
devaient pas paraître qui qui c'est
toujours un peu le même comme un peu pas
le même mais c'est le même sujet si je
comprends bien c'est même sujet on ne me
sujet voilà c'est ça je suis comme je
suis dans mes livres à moi il faut que
je mette au courant parce que vous
publiez tellement vous la dernière fois
il ya pas longtemps c'était pour
spartacus avait pas longtemps stoehr
proches thierry a pas du tout non au
contraire je suis ravie quand vous êtes
là max vraiment je voulais dire aussi
des ravis de vous avoir
alors cette fois c'est pour un livre qui
s'appelle fier d'être français chez
fayard
mais aussi pour un papier que vous avez
publié mercredi dernier dans le figaro
et pour réagir sur cet article
j'appelle djamel bouras
bonsoir jamais
alors ce papier s'appelle islam ne rien
abandonné à la politique de l'apaisement
alors vous utiliser ce mot apaisement
pendant tout l'article et puis à la fin
on apprend que ce mot étaient employés
au moment de la capitulation de munich
par les diplomates
devant la menace de hitler on disait
c'est pas possible on peut pas aller à
la guerre
on va donc pratiquer une politique
d'apaisement et munich a été en
septembre 1938 le grand moment où on a
abandonné d'ailleurs les tchèques les
quais qu'on les a livrés d'une certaine
manière et on a dit on a réussi la
politique d'apaisement et chamberlain
qui est l anglais le grand ministre des
affaires étrangères a dit c'est la paix
pour notre temps et et churchill qui
était dans l'opposition a dit croit
avoir la paix ils ont perdu l'honneur
ils auront le déshonneur et ils auront
la guerre
donc même si la situation n'est pas la
même
je sens et c'est un peu pourquoi j'ai
écrit ce livre aussi fier d'être
français je sens chez nous en france en
europe
le refus de voir un certain nombre de
réalités et on entend parler d'ailleurs
le mot d'apaisement qui est un bon mot
le mot n'apaise mans moi je suis tout à
fait un type apaisé je suis pour la paix
mais le mot d'apaisement dans mon esprit
et dans l'histoire il veut dire en fait
capitulation il veut dire ça il veut
dire capitulation et je crois qu'il ne
faut jamais capitulé quand on est sûre
de ses valeurs et ça vaut pour tout le
monde et je crois en même temps qu'il ne
faut pas avoir ce qu'on appelle la
politique de l'autruche c'est à dire se
mettre la tête dans le sable
donc voilà le sens de sang de cet
article mais
en même temps je le dis à djamel bouras
en même temps je suis fier d'être
français
parce qu'il est français qui l'a emporté
sur les sur les tapis certain nombre de
médailles qui nous ont qui nous ont tous
fait plaisir vous pensé quand même
qu'aujourd'hui face à l'islamisme voir à
l'islam il ya le même danger qu'ils
avaient face à hitler à l'époque non il
faut écouter si on parle de ben laden
des terroristes de madrid et de londres
de ceux qui égorge des gens de ce qui
est c'est précisément de choisir la
violence et 2 et de tirer du coran et du
prophète la leçon de la guerre et de la
violence
ceux là qui à mon avis sont une minorité
si c'est ça oui c'est aussi dangereux
que le nazisme
je ne confonds évidemment pas l'islam
les musulmans avec ce que je crois une
minorité et c'est ça qui me révolte si
vous voulez parce que and europe où il y
a une forte population musulmane en
france c'est la deuxième religion il ya
cinq millions de musulmans dit on parce
qu'on n'a pas de statistiques précises
il ya la chance de voir naître un espace
un espace de paix dans lequel nous
pourrions nous rencontrer sur la base de
ce qui est la tradition française qui
est celle de la laïcité même si elle a
dit elle est imparfaite même si les gars
de l'inégalité même s'il ya du racisme
en fait vous le savez et vous le savez
bien je l' ai déjà dit moi je suis fils
d'italiens
j'ai été porte parole du gouvernement
alors que ma mère est italienne et mon
père étaient étaient nés en france mais
était physique alliant parler l'italien
chez moi donc moi je crois beaucoup et
je pense à vous madame je trouve que et
à djamel bouras je trouve que une des
caractéristiques de la france fier
d'être français c'est parce que nous
sommes depuis l'origine
avant même qu'il y ait une france parce
que nous sommes au bout de l'europe les
peuples se croisent dans un pays c'est
donc une terre on peut se jouer
actuellement dans les yeux dans ce 21e
siècle où peut se jouer vraiment une
entente mais il ne faut pas capituler
devant les gens qui nous manipule qui
manipule tout le monde
80 des cas max gallo que derrière ces
affaires de caricatures de mahomet si
notre rapport au monde islamique qui est
soulevée et vous dites il ya bien un
choc de civilisations
oui je crois juste évidemment je ne suis
pas partisan d'un choc du mais il faut
c'est là où je disais n'ayant pas la
politique de l'autruche écoutez j'ai
regardé la télévision france 2
d'ailleurs où elle était interviewé dans
une mosquée de la région parisienne un
homme très émouvant je pense que c'était
un sénégalais d'ailleurs et qui disait
avec beaucoup d'émotion et de sincérité
il disait en se taper il l'a répété deux
fois en se tapant le point sur la
poitrine
moi je préfère voir mourir mon père que
de voir caricaturé le prophète alors moi
je suis très ému je suis croyant aussi
je suis ému par sa et en même temps je
sais que nous avons désormais nous un
autre rapport au ca craint d'abord notre
rapport nous avons vu par exemple sur
une affiche de film
nous avons vu la croisette ce film
s'appelait amène costa gavras
nous avons vu la croix transformer en
croix gammée absolument ça voulait dire
dont tous ceux qui ont la croix pour
emblème aurait pu se sentir concerné en
disant ce sujet on nous accuse de nazis
au sujet de l'attitude de pie xii
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale
exactement si vous voulez mais nous nous
avons pris l'habitude bonnes ou
mauvaises c'est un autre débat mais nous
avons pensé parce que nous avons eu une
histoire sanglante
nous avons eu des guerres de religion
nous avons coupé des têtes nous avons
massacré nous avons chassé les
protestants nous avons persécuté les
juifs nous avons livré à certains
moments de l'est nous savons qu'il n'y a
rien de pire que l'intégrisme et qu'il
n'a rien de pire que les conflits de
religion donc nous avons construit ce
que j'appelle un espace d'un laïc dans
lequel il peut y avoir
charlie hebdo qui publient des des
caricatures mais en même temps on n'est
pas content on tourne la tête train je
vois cette affiche de costa gavras ou je
vois une femme à la place du christ je
crois que c'était nathalie rheims dans
une wii il ya eu aussi la selle de la
serbe où il ya eu aussi le pape cissé
si je suis choqué ce que je fais je
saisi les tribunaux
ouais je suis habitué à considérer ma
foi comme une affaire privée
d'une certaine manière comme une affaire
privée et là je dis qu'il ya deux
civilisations
car dans l'islam pour l'instant c'est
pas comme ça oui c'est comme ça le les a
créés très lié sa politique et rallie
quotidienne en gros les guignols ont
blasphémé le christ et se sont excusés
et se sont excusés et nous le problème
c'est que ce qu'on ressent vraiment au
fond de nous mêmes
c'est le deux poids et deux mesures nous
il ya un espèce de deux poids et deux
mesures qu'on trouve inacceptable en
tant que français sont surtout les
domaines ya deux poids deux mesures et
c'est ça qu'on reproche mais je crois je
vous interromps pour vous donner raison
je crois que ce sentiment de deux poids
deux mesures je sais et je sais qu'il
existe que vous avez raison d'avoir ce
sentiment parce qu'il est vrai qu'il y a
deux poids deux mesures mais je pense
que c'est une je pense que là il faut
que nous y mettions chacun de notre
chacun de notre de notre bonne volonté
je veux dire par exemple quand je vois
quand je vois que voltaire groff et
écrivain français qui a dénoncé le
christianisme le catholicisme qui a été
deux fois à la bastille qui appelait
d'ailleurs qu'ils avaient une sa formule
i10 et écrasons l'infâme l'infâme
c'était la religion catholique
il avait tellement peur d'être
poursuivis qui s'est installé à la
frontière de la suisse et de la france
voltaire a écrit une pièce en 1741 qui
s'appelle le fanatisme ou mahomet le
prophète 1741 ça fait partie des
classiques
quand je sais j'apprends que dans tel
village du jura afin de l'ain du pays de
gex
il ya des associations musulmanes de
français je veux dire qu'ils sont venus
dire on veut pas que cette
représentation soit prod se produise on
veut pas parce que c'est une en ou
manque de respect mais peut-être
ressent-il cela mais moi je ne veux pas
que ce qui a contribué à faire mon pays
le vôtre notre pays qui a lui donné cet
espace 2
laïcité je ne veux pas qu'on n'y renonce
ce que voulait dire en gros max gallo
c'est que finalement nous on a appris à
faire la part des choses entre ce qui
était privé et ce qui était publique
et finalement ce que vous dites
aujourd'hui c'est que les musulmans
seraient pas le faire c'était le rapport
au sacré népal mais voilà il n'est pas
le même
nous nous sommes nous vivons dans un
monde qu'on peut critiquer qui est le
monde de la dérision
vous le savez bien les médias je dirais
le monde de la dérision se moque de tout
le bloc du pape agonisant on dit que
l'autre cette panthère pop le nouveau
benoît 16 etc
on se moque on vit dans le monde de la
dérision et de la marchandise 20 le
sacré il est expulsé et une affaire
privée territoire on a déjà fait une
émission où tu me disais que tu étais
choqué quand il avait ajouté le pape
oui mais moi je suis choquée mais
monsieur c'est pas pour ça que j'ai
roulé l'ambassade
tu commencé je vais dire le pape il
trouvait scandaleux qu'on fait que parce
que benoit 16 qui était en effet il
avait 14 ou 15 ans et il était dans les
jeunesses militarisée du nazisme
on a dit ce pape allemand on l'a
représenté comme un pape nazis ont parce
qu'il était totalement vous êtes allez
vous êtes choqués mais vous laisser
faire je suis choqué et en même temps le
fait que ça se fasse
me satisfait - parce que ça veut dire
que nous avons co et l'hébreu à peu nous
avons mis la religion dans la sphère
privée
je vous pose une question à quoi ça sert
tout ça la personne qui fait la
caricature à quoi ça sert dans quelle
objectivité
pourquoi on fait ça moi c'est une
question se pose pourquoi écouter - qui
servent à qui sert le secret rica tueur
je les trouve nul ce qui m'intéresse là
dans l'histoire des caricatures un
journal danois à la fin septembre fait
des caricatures ça c'est la
responsabilité du journal danois
pourquoi ont-ils fait ça la politique du
danemark parce qu'il y avait une il ya
eu il ya eu ce cinéaste néerlandais qui
s'appelle theo van gogh qui a fait un
film qui a été égorgé par un néerlandais
musulmans et qu'il a qui l'a égorgée et
il ya eu dans tous les pays scandinaves
ça eu énormément de déco cet assassinat
dans les pays à partir et dans la zone
des pays scandinaves et en hollande et
les danois semble-t-il enfin ce qui est
à la tête de ce
journal ont eu le sentiment que la peur
faisait naître une autocensure un que
sais-je profondément choqué les
musulmans danois
je suis tout à fait d'accord ce qui me
choque c'est que les imams danois de
nationalité danoise sont partis faire
une tournée en egypte avec ses dessins
et en ajoutant et ça ça semble tout à
fait prouvé en ajoutant des dessins
encore plus ignominieux que je n'ai même
pas à décrire c est pourquoi je veux
dire n'ont ils pas mener ce combat à
l'intérieur de leur pays le danemark et
pourquoi ont ils été embrasé le
moyen-orient qui a ses propres problèmes
c'est la communauté musulmane je suis
d'accord mais je crois que quand on
s'enracine quand on est citoyen d'un
pays on règle les problèmes à
l'intérieur de ce pays en tenant compte
des 1 des valeurs du système de ce pays
et ça c'est ça qui me c'est ça qui
m'inquiète ce qui m'inquiète c'est que
les imams qui ont pris ce risque
je les accuse de d'avoir en effet
provoquer aggravé cette incompréhension
entre les civilisations est fait d'un
problème qui était réel en tout cas qui
devaient être discutés fait d'un
problème réel
un problème qui est devenu international
où vous avez des gens qui sont morts
vous avez des bâtiments qui ont été
brûlées ce qui n'est rien mais des gens
sont morts vous avez une violence et une
incompréhension qui est encore plus
forte
et personne à y gagner sauf ceux hélas
jeu ça c'est mou c'est mon idée sauf
ceux qui pensent qu'il y à un danger
pour l'intégrisme
si l'islam européen devient un islam qui
accepte et qui se trouve bien de vivre
dans un univers qui est un univers
laïque et il y a donc une tentative de
manipulation forte de ce point de vue là
c'est de la provocation de même rappelé
en france il faut savoir que charlie
hebdo surtout françois sont en déficit
françois va bientôt fermer etc
donc il faut qu'ils vendent du papier
donc c'est de la provocation et je crois
qu'il faut qu'on soit beaucoup plus sage
que ça qu'on rende pas dans ces
provocations et c'est pour ça que c'est
l'autocensure c'est djamel si on commet
ce que je veux dire si on commence à pas
faire de dessin pour pas choquer les
musulmans n'ont rien que pour moi c'est
de l'auto sont soir c'est l'un des
quatre élections à la liberté
d'expression
pour moi la liberté d'expression et le
respect font partie sont mariés ensemble
tu peux moi je suis pour la liberté
d'expression
mais si je vais blessé une personne
pourquoi de blesser la personne
ce qui m'intéresse c'est le mot respect
car j'ai beaucoup lu ces temps ci décrit
notamment de tariq ramadan par exemple
et il dit il faut que les musulmans ne
réclame pas plus de censure mais ils
réclament davantage de respect le seul
problème c'est que si le respect c'est
ça aboutit en fait à une censure par
exemple le porte parole de la mosquée de
genève et je cite enfin vous pouvez
vérifier mes sources
quand on voulait faire la lecture à
genève récemment dans un mois de cette
pièce de voltaire de voltaire qui
s'appelle le fanatique ou mahomet le
prophète il a dit nous sommes pour la
liberté d'expression mais nous voulons
le respect mais si le respect abouti à
la censure alors à ce moment-là il
soyons clairs disons disons nous nous
considérons que tout ce qui est
attentatoire et blasphématoire pour nous
ne doit pas avoir droit de cité au moins
c'est clair
ch de la france est un melting-pot qui
est enfin très mélangée avec c'est pour
moi c'est très riche il faut quand il
faut que c'est plutôt rassembler les
idées qui nous unissent
tout le monde est d'accord avec toi la
france est d'accord mais si moi j'ai
envie de faire une caricature sur
mahomet ou sur un rat main ou sur
jésus-christ il faut que j'ai le droit
de le faire tu commences à la france
thierry fermé à ce que mon avis comme
tout à l'heure on parlait faut que tu
sois dans l'empathie quand tu sais que
tu vas blessés dit
une personne pourquoi tu vas les blessés
pourquoi si la liberté ces cinq ans et
la liberté alors pas deux poids deux
mesures la liberté pour tout le monde
c'est à dire la liberté pour tout le
monde il ya des personnes qui ont été
refusés de télévision et à des personnes
qui parlent que une personne comme de
données qui a fait un rabbin enfin café
un colon juif etc tous ces dvd ne sont
plus dans les pactes on empêche de venir
on empêche médiatiquement le voit plus
alors que lui c'est un comique et qu'il
a il est où
c'est vrai qu'il n'a pas été condamné et
après on fasse confiance à la loi non à
la république tchèque le cas dieudonné
est intéressant en l'occurrence ce qui
est justement ce qui me gêne dans la
censure c'est qu'elle est souvent
exercée par un une poignée de personnes
par an tout cas sans aucun respect pour
ceux qui sont en face c'est à dire qu'on
ne laisse pas le choix aux gens qui sont
en phase ii jugés par même ses dessins
ils ont ils existent j'ai le droit moi
de dire ça me choque oui j'ai le droit
de moi de dire je les trouve bien et
puis je veux qu'il y en ait d'autres
ou alors il faut pas faire ça mais je
veux dire chacun est responsable de deux
de ses pensées de et donc je pense que
la censure elle n'est pas acceptable
parce qu on est chacun on a un il faut
il faut le respect de chacun on est
chacun digne d'un avis et je trouve ça
choquant de dire toi tu ne verras pas
céder 100 parce que ses dessins ne sont
choquants ils vont provoquer des
violences en quoi c'est acceptable moi
je trouve que on est ou serait on doit
être tous responsables et que si ce
n'est pas le cas c'est ça qu'il faut
régler le problème c'est de savoir
pourquoi et des manifestations violentes
le problème savoir pourquoi quand on
n'est pas d'accord on ne manifeste pas
dans l'apaisement c'est à dire
sereinement on n'est pas d'accord mais
en le disant et non pas en faisant des
actes violents
mon avis c'est ça qu'il faut régler et
non pas dire il ne faut pas qu'ils et
elles chose il faut pas qu'on écrive ou
telle chose il faut pas qu'on dessine
telles choses parce que vous comprenez
messieurs dames
tout ça va provoquer des violences non
moi j'ai pas dit ça
alors pas de sens à la vie quelque chose
d'important s'est levé clair quand on
parle de liberté d'expression on a dit
un mot important
la responsabilité c'est qu'un
journaliste doit avoir une
responsabilité un politique d'avoir une
responsabilité un philosophe doit avoir
une responsabilité aussi ça c'est très
important le mans qui l'a dit ouais j'ai
jamais dit que j'étais pour la violence
loin de là il ya juste un an le cas
pourtant j'aimerais dire il ya eu la loi
taubira
ouais d'accord il ya eu plusieurs lois
qui ont été faites contre
l'antisémitisme que je trouve
extraordinaire je trouve et moi je fais
un appel aujourd'hui au ministre azouz
begag qui est là où
de villepin de faire une loi contre
l'islamophobie tout simplement lui
envoie tous ses produits les gants je
suis jeté à l'eau je suis est contre la
loi taubira contre la loi gayssot et je
suis comme l'ensemble des des historiens
et d'autres et d'autres d'autres
intellectuels employeur ce mot je suis
pas pour que des je pense qu'il ya des
lois en france qui sont contre le
racisme contre l'antisémitisme il ya des
lois sur la presse contre la diffamation
on peut poursuivre on peut demander la
saisie d'un journal en référé on a
d'ailleurs demandé la saisie de charlie
hebdo mais avait un vice de procédure
l'avocat l'a reconnu il s'est pris tard
etc
il ya donc un ensemble de lois nous
n'avons pas a fixé par la loi
un certain nombre de règles ce qu'on
peut dire quand même c'est vrai
qu'actuellement il ya une loi gayssot
contre l'antisémitisme et surtout le
négationnisme il ya une loi taubira sur
les noirs pourquoi les musulmans y aura
pas une loi contre l'islamophobie tu dis
pas si j'y vois là si je dis ben laden
est un criminel
oui ils se réclament de lui pas fait ça
c'est pas de sa chanson serait qui se
réclament du prophète
ils déclarent chacun et chaque à chaque
instant ce qui égorge les gens disent
nous nous agissons au nom du prophète
personnes égorgées rien du tout n'aurait
on dit en français par vos phobies est
une notion qui est extrêmement vague je
veux dire si je me mets à critiquer d'un
point de vue at et si je me mets à
critiquer l'islam et si je jeu du fait
la lecture du coran je fais une lecture
qui est considéré comme je pense à
salman rushdie qui est considéré comme
satanique
alors je suis victime de la loi d'
islamophobie ça veut dire que ça
m'interdit d'analysé tel et tel texte
considéré sacré par un effet ces 5 à 6
malgré des pressions musulmans qu'est ce
que ça veut dire
c'est une personne qui prient sur dieu
et sur son prophète
tous les jours qui pour lui
danser dans ses convictions le prophète
est au dessus de ses parents ça
correspond bien à ce que disait la danse
est une personne mais une bombe sur la
tête du prophète
ça veut dire que quoi 1 milliard 500
millions de musulmans sont des
terroristes et sont des mecs qui vont
poser des bombes ne met pas parce que
vous nous parler d'histoire en tant
qu'historien très souvent mais personne
nous rappelle l'histoire de l'andalousie
où quand les musulmans étaient au
pouvoir
ils défendent et les juifs et les
chrétiens on peut tout à fait c'est de
l'image tout est dans le monde entier où
les trois religions vivait à merveille
personne ne la rappelle à l'époque
d'avicenne ou à l'époque de d'averroès
ou à l'époque de personnes nous l'a
rappellé chine cette histoire est tout à
fait le nen autre exemple aujourd'hui il
ya un an de ça j'ai fait un appel il ya
un film qui est merveilleux qui est
tourné par anthony quinn et irène papas
ce qui est le messager qui expliquent
l'histoire de la religion
comment elle est arrivée etc etc
un film magnifique il est passé en 70
219 dans les dossiers de l'écran
darmangeat mots comment ça se fait qu'il
repasse par la télévision depuis 26 ans
je ne suis pas je peux pas vous répondre
je jouais vraiment moi c'est tout des
questions je pose à chaque fois là
justement ça quand je pense qu'on va
continuer dans les questions parce qu'on
va sortir un peu des caricatures de
mahomet la séparation des hommes et des
femmes dans les piscines par exemple où
le fait que certaines patientes
musulmanes refusent
de se faire soigner par des médecins
hommes est ce que ça te choque en tant
que musulman les deux points et deux
mesures
c'est aujourd'hui les chrétiens dans
toutes les grandes villes sont en place
ils ont lors ils ont leurs noms leurs
écoles etc
il ya la communauté juive qui a réussi à
à à créer ces écoles etc nous le
problème si que les musulmans ne sont
pas organisés ils n'ont pas dit leurs
écoles si puisque si t'es pas d'accord
avec l'école publique
t'as qu'à faire ton école t'as qu'à
faire ton école comme ça tu as ta
piscine taton tâter séparation etc
c'est à eux de s'organiser et de faire
leur école va c'est la fin de
l'universalisme républicain
mais alors pourquoi on le laisse faire à
d'autres et pas moi c'est ça moi je veux
une loi pour tout le monde et c'est la
même pour tout le monde c'était si ces
principes c'est le principe même de la
république je ne dis pas que ça existe
dans les faits mais notre projet le
projet français c'est celui là c'est à
dire faire en sorte que le lien entre la
nation française est celui qui fait
partie de cette collectivité est un lien
personnel un lien personnel de citoyens
d'individus si vous ne préservons pas
cette singularité française imparfaite
aujourd'hui je suis d'accord imparfaite
mais si nous a préservés ont pas eh bien
nous serons une coupe nous serons une
série de communautés éclatées vous
pensez max que c'est une capitulation
c'est d'accepter que les piscines soit
soit je pense à pelé moi j'appelle ça
une capitulation rampante capitulation
rampante qui n'a pas besoin de deux
d'expression violente mais qui fait
qu'ils aient il existe des groupes de
pression des gens viennent et parce par
précisément parce qu'on ne croit plus à
notre système de valeurs à ce que nous
avons bâti difficilement à ce qui n'est
pas parfait à ce moment là on accepte et
on crée on crée des piscines pour les
femmes ont créé bref on va accepter que
la pièce de voltaire ne soit pas
représentée on va accepter que tel
journal ne puisse pas reproduire si ça
lui chante et même si je pense que c'est
tout à fait stupide qui pro qu'il passe
telle ou telle caricature
et puis surtout je crois je veux
répondre à
à jamel sur ce point qui a dit les
catholiques sont installés les juifs
sont installés avec leurs écoles etc
pardon c'est tout à fait la vérité mais
il faut admettre thiam elle c'est comme
ça et je le dis avec beaucoup de calme
et sans esprit de supériorité que le
socle de cette france et de cette europe
est un socle judéo-chrétien pourtant mon
grand père quand il a fait la guerre
pour la france qu'on l'amenait et qu'on
lui a amenés à manger mais la grand mère
à la belle foulard personne n'a dit
c'est un musulman et ateliers différents
des autres je dis pas si comme je les ai
entendus comme je me le suis entendu
dire à savoir la phrase suivante dans un
débat télévisé il ya quatre ou cinq ans
quelqu'un qui m'a dit vous avez des
églises partout dans tous les villages
nous n'avons pas de mosquée moi je suis
pour qu'on construise des mosquées je
suis pour que vous ne priez pas dans les
dents les dents les sur les trottoirs
parce que les six mois il ya des églises
qui ne servent à rien on problème les
églises le droit de ne pas prêts dans
les affaires mais ne pas admettre la
réalité historique de ce pays
je veux dire qui ce pays je regrette un
socle judéo chrétien c'est comme ça
comme l'europe
on peut on peut le regretter on peut
dire ça va changer dans 100 ans ce sera
différent peut-être mais il n'empêche
que c'est comme ça aujourd'hui et c'est
que tu as encore que c'est pour ça que
nous la jeunesse on est là pour essayer
de changer les choses mais pour faire
des choses là encore je veux dire la
jeunesse soyons soyons clairs en c'est
la réputation telle dans un autre sens
aux problèmes de la france
le problème de la france c'est différent
dans les bras en france c'est de servir
ensemble toutes les jeunesses tout les
jeux sur toutes les jeunesses toutes les
jeunesses pas seulement ce n'est pas
vous qui êtes seulement la jeunesse il
ya toutes les jeunesses je me dis que
j'étais
transition transition arrive maintenant
plus précisément au livre donc ils
s'appellent fier d'être français
et vous dites c'est la première phrase
du livre il faut bien que quelqu'un
monte sur le ring et 10
je suis fier d'être français donc c'est
vous qui vous y est collé max va écouter
oui je me suis collé et cela je suis
peut-être pas le mieux placé puisque je
le répète on par les italiens chez moi
il ya 50 ans ou 60 ans donc
mais il n'empêche que je suis français
et je reconnais que je suis très attaché
à ce pays qui est mon pays je passais
participer à sa vie et il m'a donné en
même temps le moyen par l'école de la
république moi fils d'un milieu
prolétarien d'immigrés dumas de i bat
donner le moyen de faire un parcours le
soient bons ou mauvais ce de notre débat
mais j'ai fait un parcours
je n'ai pas rencontré de racisme même si
chez moi on en a souffert moi
personnellement j'en ai pas rencontré et
je ne pense pas que la france soit un
pays raciste et même s'il y a des
racistes en france même si nous sommes
d'accord avec vous même s'il y a des
racistes en france mais nous sommes
faits comme partout comme dans le pays
par ne sommes pas un pays raciste
les français ne sont pas du tout
islamophobe absolument ça c'est parce
que mes mais il ya dans ce que certains
intellectuels c'est tout quelques
politiques
l'art est ce que vous dites vous on a eu
aussi pas mal de déclinologues là depuis
quelques temps vous en prenez aux
déclinologues mais je comprends et je
mens je vais vous dire je m'en prends à
ce que j'appelle les élites juin 10 en
plaçant les élites j'en fait apparemment
peut-être partie mais par mon mode de
vie
je me sens pas moi membres du g20 mais
j'en prends aux élites qui qui ont pensé
à un moment donné que les nations
s'était finie la france était fini et
quand vous entendez cette france est
déjà albert camus l'écrivait ya
longtemps cette france comme si elle
était la seule coupable parmi des
nations qui serait sain épuré banon nous
sommes pas meilleurs que les autres mais
nous sommes pas pire - et même à
certains moments je trouve que nous
avons dans l'histoire des hommes
nous avons joué un rôle positivement par
exemple quand nous avons créé cet espace
de vie en commun un parfait je le répète
mais qui a été créée quand même donc
vous êtes contre la repentance
généralisée
la france qui s'accusent de tous les
crimes et qui a honte de ce qu'elle a
été bouzid il est temps de redresser la
tête et d'en finir avec la repentance
quoi bien sûr parce que vous ne pouvez
pas vous ne pouvez pas regarder ses com
et là je pense que jamel sera d'accord
avec moi
on ne peut pas regarder son passé le
sien propre en tant que personne comme
un univers négatif noir et avancer il
faut avoir de l'estimé de soi il faut
avoir de l'estimé de soi il faut être
fier de ses origines il faut on peut
mais il regarder lucidement parents pas
en ferrain un palet mais les regarder
avec leur nombre et leur lumière comme
on dit et c'est comme ça qu'on avance et
de dire on s'est trompé d'absolument
tout à fait de demander des excuses à
des peuples qu'on a qu'on a décimé ou
qu'on a qu'on a massacré oui bien sûr
pourquoi pas ça c'est l'un des codes
morale d'accord prenons les choses tout
à fait frontalement jugeons de la
colonisation française
par exemple la colonisation française
moi j'ai toujours dit et écrit dans tous
les débats
j'ai beaucoup participé la colonisation
un péché originel la colonisation c'est
une conquête militaire par des gens plus
fort qui oppriment des gens plus faibles
donc quoi que vous construisiez d'aider
des ports des immeubles des villes des
instituts construire par les indigènes
quoique quoi que nous laissions de
positif ce sera toujours affectées d'un
signe négatif parce que la blessure et
c'est normal mais si on veut juger ça
faut comparer par rapport à quoi
par rapport à la colonisation anglaise
par rapport à la colonisation allemande
par rapport à ce qui se faisait à
l'époque
là nous sommes dans la réalité et à ce
moment là nous voyons que nous sommes
pas du tout les pires en au contraire
nous sommes pas du tout les dimanches à
debrecen
le truc 2006 si vous dites si vous
d'accuser si vous regardez seulement -
la france en disant criminels
colonisation et cetera fait non
condamnées toutes les cotisations non
qu'elle soit en gaz qu'elle soit pour
comparer pur jus
g il faut comparer les choses faut
comparer les choux ce qui veut dire
c'est qu'en france avait beaucoup de
gens qui trouvaient que la colonisation
a coûté trop cher parce que ça coûtait
de l'argent tout ça est que yam le
fameux raymond cartier qui disait la
corrèze plutôt close en baisse depuis
nous sommes un pays contradictoires il
ya toujours eu en france des opposants à
la colonisation n'ont pas non pas
simplement pour des raisons économiques
qui disent ça coûte plus cher ça coûte
trop cher on ferait mieux d'investir
dans les routes en corrèze ou ailleurs
par exemple mais il ya des gens qui
étaient opposés à la colonisation pour
des raisons tout à fait moral clémenceau
disait à jules ferry
vous nous a parlé de race supérieure
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire moi je
suis pour je suis pas du tout a dans
cette optique là ces gens là étaient
était du côté des colonisés et ils
étaient français donc ne confondons pas
une sorte de culpabilité collective qui
écrase le pays c'est pas possible très
bien alors vous dites max gallo pour
vous le vainqueur en 2007 sera celui qui
sera capable de restituer aux français
cette capacité d'être fiers d'être
français
mais oui je crois que l'élection ne se
jouera pas sur des questions de pas
seulement en tout cas et padacke pas
d'abord sur des questions de savoir
contrat première embauche
je crois que c'est je crois que nous
arrivons à un moment où on a besoin
d'eux de savoir dans quel pays on vit
est ce qu'on veut faire de ce pays et
c'est ça qui sera la question
max gallo qui est d'être français
c'est éviter
[Musique]